[Música]
y comenzamos de revista de prensa en
directo américa de france 24 y miércoles
acompañado por supuesto de rosa pérez
más de euros a bienvenida abrimos con un
análisis de el kef independent que
plantea el golpe compra tu contra putin
una ilusión o una posibilidad real que
está pasando buenos días a gol pues bien
el periodista que escribe este artículo
o lexus parte de la premisa que la
inteligencia ucraniana reveló el 20 de
marzo que una élite rusa estaría
preparando un golpe de estado contra lo
que el periodista se refiere como la
dictadura de vladimir putin ahora bien
el propio periodista zhúkov dice que si
bien la afirmación puede ser dudosa hay
distintos analistas que la contemplan
eso sí algunos consideran que es
altamente improbable que se acabe
desencadenando este golpe de estado
mientras que otros ven este escenario
como inevitable y empecemos por acá
porque él según el analista político
ruso dmitri oreshkin si la guerra se
alarga mucho y la situación económica
interna dentro de rusia se deteriora
mucho más es posible que putin se caiga
como símbolo y que el sistema acabe
colapsando y que pierda si el presidente
ruso pues tanto el apoyo de la élite
económica como el apoyo popular pero por
otro lado un excoronel de los fsb de los
servicios secretos de moscú gennady
gudkov dice que pues es completamente
una ilusión no este posible golpe de
estado que cuando se prepara algo así se
hace en completo secretismo y se conoce
ya pues post factum con los hechos
consumados y dice que no es tan
importante para putin el apoyo popular y
el apoyo de los oligarcas sino más bien
de los hombres fuertes del ejército y de
los servicios secretos aunque pues se
complique la guerra putin podría
permanecer en el poder asegura aunque
eso pues les suponga mantenerse de forma
todavía más autoritaria pues delante del
crimen ahora rosa pasamos a ver el
monstruo está en bourg un texto de
pierde unido habla de la razón por la
que el contexto de la guerra en ucrania
muchos apoyos al kremlin vienen desde
áfrica
esto pues se refiere empieza este texto
con la resolución de naciones unidas ha
condenado pues la invasión rusa de
ucrania en que pues por amplia mayoría
los países del mundo pues condenaron
esta guerra sin embargo de los 35 países
que se abstuvieron 16 fueron africanos y
además eritrea votó en contra de la
condena a rusia y 8 países africanos no
votaron y bien este artículo relaciona
pues el apoyo a la rusia actual con la
lógica que se forjó durante la guerra
fría no en que la unión soviética
apoyaba pues los movimientos de
liberación anti racistas
antiimperialistas y anticoloniales en
africano y que ese pues apoyo de la
unión soviética en su momento
se se relaciona con el rechazo al
colonialismo y el imperialismo
tradicional de occidente que hoy pues
desencadenan un rechazo también a la
otan y en un apoyo implícito a putin más
allá pues de los vínculos actuales entre
pues a la rusia de hoy la federación
rusa y los países africanos como uno de
las personas citadas en este artículo
putin al menos no tiene sangre de la
colonización en sus manos y más allá de
los países que comparten pues vínculos
históricos podemos ver este giro no en
alianzas internacionales muy claramente
en el caso de malí por ejemplo raúl y
más ampliamente rosa economics publicó
un mapa con los apoyos globales de putin
exacto y economista después divide los
gobiernos del mundo en cinco categorías
los que condenan a rusia que los vemos
de color azul o oscuro en los que vemos
pues a la otan y a colombiano este
aliado estratégico de la alianza
transatlántica así como a japón o
australia los que estarían alineados con
occidente en un azul más clarito los que
apoyan a rusia con este rojo fuerte que
vemos pues a venezuela cuba nicaragua a
siria a belarús eritrea o no me han mar
los neutrales entre los que vemos a
india brasil arabia saudí o suráfrica y
por otro lado los que estarían alineados
con rusia no en este color más rosado
más bajito entre los que destacan por
ejemplo argelia malí como comentábamos
china y aquí vamos y uno de los apoyos
implícitos más importantes de moscú es
el gobierno de beijing hablamos del
gobierno el presidente sigue un ping y
de aquí el titular de al yazira sobre
como como los medios estatales chinos
hablan de la guerra en ucrania dice eeuu
es el villano es un artículo de rachel
swing exactamente como comentábamos no
chinas uno de los apoyos pues implícitos
a rusia a pesar de que oficialmente
mantenga esta posición pues un poco
neutral o que diga pues que hay que
resolver pacíficamente el conflicto por
lo tanto más allá de los juicios de
valor si uno entiende más o menos cómo
funcionan las alianzas internacionales
no es de extrañar pues a lo que explica
este artículo es que los medios
estatales chinos están reproduciendo
pues a bajo órdenes del gobierno de
beijing el discurso del kremlin y que
cada vez que se refieren a lo que sucede
en ucrania no hablan de invasión ni de
guerra sino de pues preocupaciones
legítimas de seguridad que tiene que ser
discutida por todas las partes y esto lo
constatamos hoy mismo por ejemplo pues
con el editorial del 'la times' al que
hacemos referencia aquí constantemente
para mostrar la posición de china pues
en esta guerra y es que particularmente
en el editorial del 'global times'
actual hace referencia al incidente de
butch a las palabras tampoco son alas al
azar y dice que rusia aportó pruebas
empíricas de que eso fue un montaje
ucraniano dice sea como sea siempre es
injustificable la matanza de civiles
pero lo que es reprochable es que eeuu
quien inició dice la crisis ucranianos
otra vez pues importancia de las
palabras no esté haciendo esfuerzos para
promover la paz que dice el diario
argentina rusa pues el diario de
argentina lo que dice es que puede ser
lo que pasó en muchas más generalmente
lo que está pasando en ucrania tiene
muchos puntos en común con lo que pasó
en chechenia o en siria básicamente lo
que dice es que rusia parte de su
superioridad numérica para seguir la
siguiente estratégica es la siguiente
estrategia y es partir del principio que
con una ofensiva indiscriminada contra
la población civil
al final va a acabar pues doblando la
resistencia local y que la población va
a acabar prefiriendo cualquier salida
pacífica así sea puedes aceptar un
gobierno impuesto por moscú oa fin no al
kremlin así es rosa gracias entonces por
toda esta información nos vemos mañana
con más revista de prensa pasamos a
analizar nuestro primer tema al día